okay I'm to this video playing promise
Tomas from Norway and let's see gannett
chigorin I get this so often recently I
really should should look at this
opening 5 hmm see 594 the anthesis it is
it is a weird opening sometimes but
quite interesting this is noah question
can I just develop with 93 maybe just
try play simple chess check
trying to get some pressure on the
queenside now this was quickly plate
looks like bit of a committal move
weakening the queenside but ok I've got
a double porn and you five is also
potentially week so look it's not dumb
everything's not rosy for white as well
okay Bishop g5 yeah I want to provoke f6
it seems like a good idea
okay come on let's let's play play very
simple chest now and try to play against
the seaborne night be five or 94 and
then I'm getting something Rock to c6
yeah this is very simplistic probably
not not good enough form for an edge but
still I'm not quite sure how black
should defend him hmm this is
interesting try to get the the Bishop to
g4 but then I'm quite quick here let's
try with Roxy 6 Roxy one I mean you
cannot play a 5 because I well maybe he
can these six Queen f7 gasps that looks
like a to do that ok so
yeah b2 is hanging
okay if he ever takes on d father can
take c7 what I'm wondering is this f5
still in the in general I mean at the
moment it's not it's not on but let's go
like that with secure the night for the
moment oh this is good news makes it
more difficult to play a five so Quincy
to Quincy for or something like that
Quincy tween rock t5 Roxy seven now one
possible move thought so night g32 f5
yeah hard to say I mean many interesting
moves or ideas
this is exchanging d5 47 hoping for
their take activity on some drank I had
other moves I can I could have played in
many other things like kingi to
improving a bit on there also was Quincy
for maybe this was the right one I don't
know giving up be two for the moment but
getting C's having back and keeping the
depot I think he just should just take
on d5 now Wow
yeah the our queen said she was probably
just bad why did I allow this I Quincy
for would have stayed on this diagonal
and now no idea what's going on ok let's
take here first hmm
this is surprising I think I'm very
quick now so you look at this the Queen
move takes and Quincy eight am I not
promoting with the deep own I think I'm
promoting with the depot
Queen anywhere or AC is he able to play
a somewhat a Quincy form
wait wait from just full moon the check
King each one had there is no mate come
on this is just there is nothing Quincy
for King edge one and no no no attack
wats either and Queen takes I just play
Quincy 8 and promote the deep on check
check
d7
black resigns yeah he just just
blundered him in a very tense position I
was really unsure I mean here I already
was very unsure what to do Quincy for
was also interesting but let's just look
at this just for moon yeah this is in
fact already winning for white he
doesn't have any of any attack the only
thing is that this d6 was was really
easy to play for me so maybe she can try
something else to stay up trouble what
should he do a probably computer gives
crew in here trying to switch over but i
have f 6 cm by then d5 we can can take
him you have very complicated stuff
queen bee three back heads to the
computer suggestion yeah i'm not sure
about this position at all probably a
black should be okay I mean the comp
gives white some edge would move my king
position not till not term it's not safe
yeah it's really a bit really unclear
yeah thanks for watching